don't tell men what you want or what
happened to you in the past yeah if they
ever ask you like oh what do you want in
a relationship and you tell them they're
going to fit that mold until they can't
anymore and their real face shows so
whenever
somebody asks you like oh what are you
looking for just tell them well just
show me what you are and i'll let you
know if it works for me or not that's
the thing is that i felt like a shitty
person and this is a shitty thing
yeah yeah but i like went was going
through his phone and it became like a a
second nature thing and i had never
looked through any other boyfriend's
phones am i interested yes what that's
weird and then it really ate me up and
then later on i found out he'd cheat i
was like i wasn't insecure that was
right yeah they were throwing it on it
was deflection that same thing happened
to me like where i was the remember the
topless photo i told you like where the
oh no boobs are funny and i was like i
don't know if this is a joke look any
guy that comes up to you make him
himself the victim i always got cheated
on yeah i always got broken up with uh
all my exes are crazy no red flag walk
away
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
big moves
hi hi there's three of us here
today the three of us uh let's introduce
who's here first and foremost our
beautiful incredible intelligent
successful
guest
who do we have hello everybody uh stacy
here
and then we also have oh me who's also
successful beautiful intelligent
i like to be picked on you guys okay
she's kind of a dum-dum honestly
nicki lima
and i am gina in today's topic we're
talking about
women's uh women telling us the
uh love bombing signs they recognize in
their relationship with partners family
and friends what gina just did to both
of us yeah just bombing us with love
our hearts out later
this is a uh article that we found on
buzzfeed
and
i can relate heavily
you've been practicing a lot how do you
know i've been practicing a lot you know
that's what i do i love bomb and then i
destroy you and leave you afterwards
i feel like you got bombed on i did i
did get love bombed on tell us about it
uh so for those of you who don't know
love bombing is what people do in the
beginning of a relationship to get you
hooked on them uh and it's just like
this it's a manipulative tactic
but what's the difference between
somebody courting you and somebody love
bombing you uh love bombing i feel like
it's a lot more
intense
it almost sounds like it's just
so
unrealistic like whoa you're talking
about marriage already within the first
few weeks you know like and it's kind of
catered to you and what they know that
you want to hear or need to hear exactly
and uh we're saying things like i i you
know i think i love you
and it's just super super duper intense
leaving a little note sleeping all the
cutesy stuff that you see in movies like
wow do you know
really quick so i don't know how you
guys ever watched the show are you the
one no no okay so it's an f it's a show
on mtv but like they play old seasons on
netflix and
i have never experienced love bombing
but on that show basically you have to
couple up and find like you're one
person that the expert said there's your
perfect match anyway so couples are like
farming or whatever this one guy
literally they had been there for three
days this guy was like i love this girl
i'm gonna marry this girl i just know
this girl's the one for me and all of us
ate it up right we're like yeah he just
really must love her blah blah
literally a week after he was like f
this girl
i hate her
he would be like why are you even
talking to me like it was crazy yeah
to watch it
go from like one to the other like
literal articles have been written about
this guy and like his mental illnesses
because obviously he went on like a
public platform and like everybody saw
it and people were just like yeah he's
just like
wrong in the head yeah but it was like
the first time i ever watched it but i'm
sorry go ahead
but yep that happens a lot and it's not
on tv and so you feel kind of crazy
because you're like nobody watched it
because people will ask how did you and
how did you stay with that guy like how
did you end up and because they loved
bombs so hard in the beginning that you
remember those times and i think this
this is how abusive relationships start
is because you just see them the way
that you met them the first time where
they were so nice and they knew
everything about you and you just like
connected and they were just you know
that that's in them so this must be a
passing phase this
abusive part must be temporary because
he was really perfect before exactly so
what usually happens it's such a big
manipulative move it's very common with
narcissists is what they do and then
they take it away from you and you're
left with oh i wish it was just like
before we can make it go back to before
and it makes you stick around like no
i've seen how sweet you can be you can
do it again it makes you want to work
for it exactly because you're like i
know like i must have done something
that made him not pull away a little bit
but right i'm gonna get back right so
that the the the the part where they
pull back the affection and they just
changed suddenly that's how you can kind
of tell that it was love bombing in the
beginning because if somebody really
does care about you they're consistent
with their love yeah and it grows and it
grows and it grows yeah so love bombing
is just a really clever and terrible way
to just get people
addicted to but but if you're in it it
doesn't feel like it changed suddenly
right like you said it feels like one
bad day right two bad days it's been
about a week it's been a bad month it's
just a bad relationship but to you
because you're the victim of that
addiction you're the addict you're like
if i could just get it back to how we
were in the beginning yeah right so
other people your friends us we can see
it but if you're in it you're too
clouded by the emotions you don't see it
right and they'll find things to make
you see make it seem like it was your
fault that things changed and as soon as
you start pulling away they're like oh
my love exactly no but you're perfect
i'm sorry and then they go back to then
you're like
you finally get that reward yeah
oxytocin you're like oh yes like it's
finally back and then as soon as you
fall they're like
yeah you know like you be worried
[ __ ] games yeah it's crazy that's
scary and i've been through that where
it's like we get into this massive
argument and then we make up and they're
so sweet for like a week or two you know
like oh he's he understands now he said
he was gonna he got it i knew he was the
perfect guy yeah we had a heart-to-heart
talk yeah he's he he understands that he
did something wrong and then for the
next week or two he's like so nice and
it feels like old times again and then
it goes back to it and it's a vicious
cycle these people are like a million
times like they turn themselves into
whatever you need it's exactly like they
get off on like that
yeah that control thing my ex used to
like give tear felt like long speeches
about how much he like he's you know
flawed but he's gonna he's gonna he's
working on it and he's all do anything
for this relationship because he's just
like it's like i'm just the one and like
blah blah blah and then like yeah two
weeks later
back to
scummy cheating dirtbag [ __ ] yeah yeah
my ex laid in bed and cried like i'm so
happy i have you in my life and you know
we're back together and stuff like that
and then two weeks later it's the same
exact thing and they would say things
like that sounds very self-reflective
yeah i know that yeah this is why i'm
like this i know where it comes from and
i'm gonna fix it but they never do and
they'll do a gesture like so i i caught
my
ex like um he had a this is gross but he
had like a file on his computer of
all his exes but not even just exes but
people he had just hooked up with
topless sleeping topless and i found
this on his computer and i was disgusted
it was titled awesome that was like the
name of the file and
and i was just like is this a trophy
case like what is this
and [ __ ] i was in there sleeping
with topless and i don't have any
topless pictures i've never sent a nude
not shaming anybody that does that i
just don't want any leaks but i just
don't do that fact that he
non-consensual non-consensual yeah and i
was like are these people non-consensual
like what what's [ __ ] of course they
are so sleepy yes so he deletes it off
his computer but i have a hunch that's
still [ __ ] somewhere so like a month
later i just get this like he's been
doing like scummy [ __ ] and i'm like i'm
gonna find this [ __ ] thing i know
it's still here i went through all these
blank discs that were he had like blank
cds and i [ __ ] found it and it was on
there and he saved it on this like file
and so when he did this big speech like
where i caught him and then he did this
big speech about it he was like here's
every bad thing i've ever done and he
lists it all out and he's like he's like
i will never do these things to you
again like i got rid of this and i there
was another thing that he had held on to
like his ex's
shirt or something like that i can't
remember what it was but he was like i
got rid of it like i'm not holding on to
anything from past and like i used to
feel validation from these things but
now i know it's just unhealthy and all
that self-reflective [ __ ] and i'm like
and he was like crying he's like i don't
want to lose you the next day he did
this like fake christmas where he like
found a christmas tree like wrapped a
bunch of presents and it's like we had
christmas and it was like oh my god he's
so quirky and cute and stuff and then
like i found all the [ __ ] he said he
threw away oh my god i found it like i'm
like i can't believe like fool me once
fool me twice pull me [ __ ] five times
and this guy kept doing it and i was
like how am i this [ __ ] stupid
like you i was happy when i caught him
cheating because i was like that made it
way easier to let go because i don't
know even why i hung on yeah you think
that it's real i was 24 when i met him
26 when we broke up yeah yeah but we
brought like were up and down throughout
that entire thing of two years of like
being [ __ ] played i felt like
i saw a tick tock yesterday where this
guy he's in like a
a
group on facebook with just a bunch of
other dudes also like it's a big public
group and someone asked what do you guys
do with the uh private photos that your
ex has sent you and like
eight out of ten comments were men
saying
well they're my pictures to do whatever
i want to do with them they're mine i do
whatever i want with them it's like dude
that's creepy delete that yeah yeah
like they're still treating women like
property like it's mine i do whatever i
want to [ __ ] do with it like dude are
we surprised yeah i'm not surprised it's
so [ __ ] creepy like when i break up
with someone the photos and whatever i
have of him gone i barely even keep it
when they send it to you yeah right
but like these men are still like keep
it like it's like a trophy it's a trophy
and it's a possession like yeah these
women like possessions you know it's so
great but you have to be some sort of
like wrong right like not all there
because
i
every guy i've date well not every guy
not one but the two guys i dated like
very healthy men very like oh yeah those
are my exes hope they're doing well but
i don't want anything to do with yeah
you know like i never had to tell them
like delete this stuff like
one time like it was like oh yeah it's
gone now like i don't really care for it
like i got a new phone or whatever the
case may be like it's just never like a
thing where
i didn't know it was an option that we
had to sit down when we first started
dating and being like can you delete all
those things yeah like even if you
haven't started dating anybody else like
it's just out of respect
for the person but i mean a lot of men
see us as objects right it's the harsh
truth it is oh my god and then
i heard just this popped into my head
because you're talking about these
pictures and stuff i was with him when
a text popped up of just a girl's
topless just a girl's tits and i was
like who the [ __ ] is this and he's like
oh this is a joke we have it's a funny
joke it's like an inside joke yeah like
it's just funny because we're talking
about how funny boobs are and i'm like
oh i'm stupid
yeah we go through those yeah um what i
learned was because people like
manipulative people like that narcissist
they mold themselves to be what you want
yeah um
i've learned that early on when you're
dating don't tell p don't tell men what
you want or what happened to you in the
past yeah if they ever ask you like oh
what do you want in a relationship and
you tell them they're going to fit that
mold until they can't anymore and their
real face shows so whenever somebody
asks you like oh what are you looking
for just tell them well just show me
what you are and i'll let you know if it
works for me or not well and like why
are we telling people what we've been
through yeah
i have never like even in my current
relationship i'm not like this guy did
this to me and that no yeah because then
you know what i allowed in the past and
then what i'll allow in the present and
i'm not about to allow that again
exactly you don't need to know yeah like
you don't need to be telling them oh he
i got cheated on and blah blah blah no
oh it didn't work out yeah has this ever
happened to you those type of guys is
the same type of guys i feel like um
where they tell you all the ways that
their ex broke their heart and like they
tell you this sob story about how awful
their ex was and what they did and then
in the future when you guys get in a
fight they're like you're just like my
ex you i can't even you're you're even
worse than her and i'm like yeah i am
get over it yeah so i made that mistake
before where i would tell them like you
know this is what i've been through
thinking like if they just know you know
then they won't do to me because they
don't want to hurt me because they like
me so much but no it shows them oh this
is what she put up with in the past that
means i can get away with it too and
more yeah
it's like a challenge exactly
so um
the x i cheated on me recently after he
and i split i found out he cheated on me
i had like this inkling of a feeling
about
that he the things he told me about his
exes were not true yeah so i decided
[ __ ] it i'm gonna reach out and just see
what happens right and so i messaged her
i was like hey this is a really weird
message i'm sending you
but
uh he and i just split
did he do the same thing to you you
don't have to answer this it's fine
whatever and she responded and that
night she and i got on the phone
together and she was a nicest girl we
got along so well we were on the phone
for six hours oh my god just hanging out
and we became friends i love that yeah
and we just became friends and then we
went through like all everything like
did he do this yeah he shared trauma
yeah it's like oh no he said that he was
like this with you and he's never been
like that with anyone else let me guess
did he say this and she's like yes
yeah yeah it's wild and then most of the
times if they're
look any guy that comes up to you make
him himself the victim i always got
cheated on yeah i always got broken up
with uh all my exes are crazy no red
flag walk away
red flag because you're going to be just
you're going to be the next one exactly
you know it's so hard like not to
empathize and be yeah oh i'm glad you
found me then
i'm like not like oh my god you guys you
guys need to be [ __ ] in the beginning
literally be a [ __ ] in the beginning
you started to get swayed onto her side
and don't be disrespectful yeah just be
like oh i got cheated on oh i'm sorry
yeah anyway yeah what are you having for
dinner you know
you know because that's how you have to
be like they don't get to just
have your empathy they get to earn it of
course you're never going to be
disrespectful let me just highlight that
but
i feel like a lot of times these people
that are manipulative they know or
instinct to nurture right
yeah and
if you treat every person like that like
i can count do there's been times where
like men have dated have cried in front
of me and i'm like just staring at them
blankly and i'm like
well you were texting her why are you
crying yeah you know and then they're
like i'm just so sorry
oh my god i didn't mean to but you did
you were texting her you know and then
i have personally i've always been very
good at like when i'm in front of them
i'm like a straight face i'm like so
good
and then when i leave i cry yeah
but
in front of them i'm just like i will
not show weakness you don't get it's not
even weakness but it's like i'm not
going to feel bad for you because you
messed up yeah you don't you no longer
get to have me you know but
it's not that i'm untouchable it's just
that in the beginning you guys all
should literally read white men love
[ __ ] it's a great book it talks about
that like how in the beginning you
should just be
it's a it's a business transaction
almost you know like you're basically
interviewing people that can potentially
be your partner right and you're doing
the choosing of the relationship right
so
yeah don't give too much in the
beginning yeah it's like it is like a
business interview like where you don't
go to a job begging for the job like you
want to know that like it's a good fit
so like tell me why tell me why i should
want to work here too not just why you
would want to hire me tell me why i
should want to be with you yeah tell me
why and then they're like and show it
with your actions yeah and like of
course you're not like what are you
bringing to the table but you're just
like i'm not going to give you
everything in the beginning you have to
earn my love my nurturing my trust
blah blah blah yeah you know you should
be courted from the beginning of the
relationship i wish i would have known
that earlier about the recording a lot
of us do you know especially since i've
always been like such a guys girl i kind
of like
you know i liked that identity of like
you know i don't need like the fancy i
don't need like to be courted i'm like
i'm a guys but i'll pay like i'll pay
for your dinner like i don't [ __ ]
care like whatever i i also made more
money than all my boyfriends so i was
like you know i don't and that wasn't
what lured me in i liked that you were
funny and that you're nice like i like
those two things i like that you're
caring and nice and funny
and then they just
never court you
yeah and then they never know to like
step it up yeah but that's you set the
standard you said the standard and we
can go into this like deeply but yeah
you should literally even if you make
more money and all he can afford to is
to take you to a taco stand if you like
him let him take you there yeah you know
if that's because
man you'll attract the type of man based
on what you accept in the beginning so
if you're like i'll pay for you oh yeah
you're going to get the type of man
that's always going to be like well
didn't you pay pay for me yeah take care
of me yeah i'm here to be your little
princess
and that doesn't make us like spoiled
will never do anything when i learned
that if i feel protected safe and cared
for
my caring side eventually feels safe
enough to come out yeah i will
reciprocate and most women always feel
like i don't want him to think i'm
taking advantage of him yeah girl you're
a millionaire you're not taking
advantage of him you know like it's
let yourself be courted today's episode
is sponsored by honey the easy way to
save when you're shopping on your iphone
or computer thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart here's how it works when
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites at checkout the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons it can find
for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop honey doesn't just work on desktop
it works on your iphone too just
activate it on safari on your phone and
save on the go
i remember going and looking all over
the internet for promo codes like first
customer codes or first buy codes and it
was such a pain but now honey just does
it for me which saves me so much money
and i usually use it on clothing
websites i remember it saving me money
on shipping and some like first time
promos too if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting the show
get honey for free at joinhoney.com big
mood that's join honey dot com slash big
mood if you run an e-commerce business
you probably feel like it's about time
people stop treating e-commerce giants
better just because they're bigger and
you are absolutely right that's why
shipstation gives e-commerce sellers of
all sizes access to the same deeply
discounted rates usually reserved for
fortune 500 companies yeah your little
etsy shop your small business you're
getting the same treatment as fortune
500 companies and shipstation doesn't
just save you money but that's a good
place to start because we all love some
extra money am i right you get deeply
discounted shipping rates that are
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies shipstation also works with
over 45 carriers so you can easily
compare rates and delivery times to
quickly find the best option every time
they work with over 300 platforms like
amazon ebay etsy and more to automate
processes like fulfillment and tracking
so you can save time managing orders oh
my god so annoying when like you're like
i want to focus on my business but then
almost all my time is spent packaging
and shipping out these orders in fact 98
of companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business yeah it makes sense
because it's so much more easy if you've
ever been you know shipping things from
a small company i i did this like when i
had an etsy shop for a while and i used
to make stickers and like send them out
to people for a little bit i had all
kind i made jewelry and stuff out all
kinds of stuff and then now i have my
jewelry business and it's just so much
easier to have a company like this where
you're saving money on shipping but
you're also saving money on like having
everything in one place so you're saving
money while making shipping easier it's
a no-brainer with all the money that i'm
saving i'm using it to put back into my
business so i could get more inventory
which equals more profit hello cha-ching
so don't let the big guys keep all the
discounts to themselves sign up using
promo code big mood for a free 60-day
trial today at shipstation.com and start
saving with every shipment that's two
whole months of discounted shipping
absolutely free just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in big
mood ship station make ship happen
speaking of courting let's get into this
article oh yeah because the first one
says
when he was courting me he was like a
romance novel when we thought he would
turn into a complete monster and do
anything to hurt me mentally and
emotionally and then when he thought i
was about to leave he would be a romance
novel again
when i finally had enough and decided i
was in fact leaving he turned so mean i
didn't even recognize him he pulled the
breakers from the breaker box and left
for four days leaving my daughter and i
would no power or water in july in
alabama oh my god
on the kitchen cabinets and refrigerator
the breakup was a year ago i've
maintained no contact he messages me
about once a month asking why i won't
talk to him he cannot believe that i
don't want him in my life anymore that's
scary they always come back yeah my ex
messaged me two weeks ago um
and he's been seeing someone else he
messaged me too
i hope so too um he messaged me two
weeks ago from his second account and
he's like oh hey so um i see you didn't
block this account um you know i'm just
starting up the second or i'm i'm
or kick starting the second account
again and i'm like [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
ass i didn't you know i didn't message
back he saw that i read it and then said
oh that wasn't supposed to be mean or
weird or anything i hope you're doing
well i'll take [ __ ]
you
do you not remember what you did yeah
yeah are you insane
yeah
he's crazy am i so periodically like
we'll find a way to like text me or
contact me yeah also like i don't even
like talking about him because i cuz you
know he like might see it or whatever
but he follows all of you
he's never met any of my friends he
follows all of this weird yeah
it's really weird it's bizarre he shows
up at things randomly that i'm at like
it's kind of stalkery so like like this
person said they if like he was a
romance novel he did everything right
but if it's such a huge stark contrast
between when he's happy and when he's
sad the way he or when he's angry the
way he treats you if it goes from
romance novel to [ __ ] monster that
means most likely the romance is not
real yeah yeah i feel like a healthy
person would be within a range of
emotions like when i'm mad i'm gonna be
mad at you with love
like i'm still respecting you i'm like i
could be so mad at my fiance but i'm
never gonna leave him outside locked out
exactly you know you're not going to
take away his basic survival yeah for
him and his daughter yeah
for sure if they're on the extremes of
both sides of the spectrum that's a huge
[ __ ] problem yeah yeah even in the
beginning you know like no matter how in
love you are because of course there's
people who get married within three
months for example and they're happy
right so like okay that wasn't a red
flag so maybe this one's normal like if
at the end of the first date they're
like i love you mm-hmm [ __ ] you barely
know me yeah you know let's pump the
brakes a little bit you know
um
it's just it's crazy like too much of
anything is not good yeah right i mean i
did uh text my friends after steve and
i's first date like do you want chick or
steak chicken or steak at the wedding
but i didn't tell him
i think that's the difference yeah
yeah like even when i met danny he was
like the first couple of days like three
days he was like oh my god i really want
to tell you something because i feel it
but i don't want to tell you because it
would be weird and then i told him i was
like i want to tell you too but it would
be weird so yeah let's wait yeah yeah so
yeah it was like a a really strong
emotion but both of us were like let's
pump the brakes a little bit you know
let's make sure that we still feel that
a few weeks from now yeah yeah or like
months from now i feel like maybe a
person that's not all there would have
been like i love you yeah yeah i love
you already let's just get married yeah
yeah or like when they're homeless and
they're like i love you can i stay the
night
and you're like they call that a
homosexual a homosexual please be
careful ladies yeah they're only with
you because they need a home oh yeah
that same guy like couldn't pay his rent
and ended up moving in with me within
the first like mine got laid off i know
i had to go through this so i can share
all these stories yes and i could tell
people what not what to look out for not
fall into we're grateful because now you
know why you love steve so much yes
because he's an awesome yes
all right the second one says i didn't
figure it out until i told him i was
leaving for real after 13 years of
marriage i agreed to one counseling
session to appease him and the trickle
uh and the words that flowed out of his
mouth about how great i am how much he
loves me blah blah was so [ __ ] fake
and inconsistent with his actions i was
physically repulsed he was so kind when
he was begging me not to leave him and
then so cruel when he realized i wasn't
backing down so cruel it was unreal
the abuse
cycle and trauma bonds are no joke yeah
that's the other thing the inconsistency
of words and actions this is the first
sign that i noticed and pointed out and
then he turned it on me he was like i'm
hurt because that's what my ex used to
say and i thought i changed that yeah
and i'm like well you didn't but like
maybe there's room and then he's like i
swear like it's gonna line up because
that really hurt me that you said that
and then it never did and i was like hey
remember when you said it hurt
well you know you're still doing that he
got so upset
and it's like okay
there has to be a point where your words
line up with your actions or that's not
real you do not understand yeah but like
don't be nice like you could be nice to
sleep now you know but like don't be
nice without your husband like you could
be nice when they're your husband when
they're dating just be mean not mean but
just like
set really firm boundaries boundaries
yeah very firm healthy boundaries i was
very bad at setting boundaries
right and so not right but like that
makes sense yeah and so now you're like
set the boundaries firmly even if you
feel guilty even if you feel bad you
know like just be firm about it oh i'm
sorry i feel bad i don't care that's my
boundary you don't get to cross it
i think it does take a certain level of
like
self acceptance and like knowing your
worth because at that time in my life i
had really low self-esteem yeah i had i
was in an abusive business relationship
where i was contracted with a guy who
was who was constantly threatened to sue
me for breaching contract even though
like this contract was really gross um
and he knew i didn't have money to
defend myself so he would constantly use
that to like get me to do the things he
wanted me to do
and and so i entered this
this romantic relationship already still
in that abusive business relationship so
there's two people
trying to like
isolate me from friends and tell me that
i'm shut down yeah pushing me down and
then then you start to feel like you're
you're not worth [ __ ] and that you don't
add value to people's lives and that you
must like these are the only two people
that care about you then and
yeah it's really bizarre how they that
can happen how you can really convince
yourself that you're not like anything
and you know you know what's kind of
crazy i feel like
now that i'm like this deep into my
relationship now i trust denny to the
point where like his words matter to me
right so now if he was to be like you're
being really mean like now i would take
it into consideration right so i can
imagine
giving somebody who you just met that
trust and them taking advantage of it
and being like you're being really
disrespectful because you're setting
boundaries if you're the kind of person
that really puts all that trust in
within the first month of dating you're
going to believe it and you're going to
be like man i am shitty i am like i'm
not worthy of his love because i'm i'm
setting boundaries i'm really bad you
know so it's not to say like you
shouldn't trust them romantically but
like don't trust his words over yours
his feelings about you over your
feelings about you you know like you
have to know who you are before you get
into a relationship so that if he says
you're being really mean for not
allowing me to come over at two in the
morning i'm not i'm just simply
respecting my space
you know because now when you really
become like in love with this person you
do trust what they say about you yeah
like now if danny was to be like you
were really mean to your sister i would
be like oh [ __ ] i was yeah you know like
because i know he comes from a place of
love but he knows you yeah and he knows
him but in the beginning if he was to be
like in the beginning of a relationship
if he was like you're being really mean
to me i'd be like deal with it
you know like these are my boundaries
and this is what i want and if you can
put up with you know and then i soften
and then you know
it blended but yeah in the beginning you
kind of have to trust yourself more than
you trust them yeah and and i think
we've said this before especially when
jess has been on the show but like i
really think everyone needs a period of
being alone like not dating anybody
not like depending on somebody you know
where you're like on your own building
your career building your self-worth
building your confidence really
solidifying who you are as a person and
no one can crack that after that but if
you haven't built that yet and you're
still in that shaky ground and someone
comes in there and they know exactly how
to work you ooh that's from the dance
that's the danger zone yeah when you
give somebody more trust than you yeah
especially the love bombing i think
really works on people who didn't get a
lot of
love or affection in their childhood and
then they come along and they're like
giving you all these things you've never
heard before
yep ooh does that work that was me and
that leads to number four i was pretty
starved emotionally as a child
when dating became a thing it was like
i'd crack the codes of being loved i was
really cute and decent looking in my
teens and early 20s so it made finding
boys really easy the first few times the
love bombing bombing turned into future
faking which is when they make promises
like yeah i want to marry you we're
going to go to hawaii yeah we named our
future kids yeah something within the
first two weeks
so the first few times the love bombing
turned into future faking and then
eventually completely slowed to a
grinding halt then turned the other
direction towards complete neglect or
being cheated on
those experiences completely destroyed
my self-worth for a while then i had to
put a guard up and really get to know
someone before believing a thing they
said it took until i was about 25 years
old to get there but i guess that's a
normal age to feel like you've really
matured yeah you have to learn about
yourself
and learn about what you're willing to
take and your boundaries and that does
take a while it makes sense that she
said 25 because that's when your frontal
cor
cortex develops yeah which is a part of
the brain that thinks about consequences
right so 25 is around the age where
you're like
become an adult who you're really gonna
be right yeah um
but
anything before that and you know a lot
of people get married a lot of people
find their true love but when you're
dealing with somebody that's like
purposefully manipulating you
that's tough
yeah because then everything that
they're doing is not real yeah it's not
a real person that you're dating that's
whatever you're getting catfished in
real life it's crazy with emotions yeah
emotional catfish emotional that's
terrifying
yeah it's uh it's it took therapy for
honestly for me to like really realize
why
i like
was drawing these types of people or
like why like i kept attracting those
types of people and like my boundary
issues and like the
i always felt like i needed to do
something to earn love i wasn't worthy
of being loved just because right being
loved like i had to like earn it somehow
and those [ __ ] people know how to
make you feel like you haven't earned it
yet exactly because they can they can
like smell it they like know your
your weaknesses and then so i was like
[ __ ] yeah i need to
like realize what i love about me first
and like fall in love with yourself
first really is like it's cliche but
it's true like you fall in love with the
things that that that you like about you
and then find someone that also sees
that yeah you know what's kind of crazy
like even if we take it one step back
like how they this person said i was the
private child of love
it's almost like it all starts in your
childhood yeah and you literally have to
love your child no matter what yeah i
don't believe in unconditional love the
only unconditional love should be to
your child
right and so
making your child love like they have to
work for love or they have to earn it by
getting good grades by cleaning their
room by taking a shower whatever it is
it's almost
training them to then seek out that same
love in the relationship absolutely
right and so like i always kind of think
like as a father having daughters it
must be so easy to mess them up because
you're the first example they see of a
man but i mean like if there's any men
listening that have daughters like you
literally have to love her so much
because everything you don't do for her
some idiot is going to come and take
advantage of her because you didn't
teach her how to be loved yep and it's
like i don't blame my dad because he he
was 24 when he became a dad yeah so he
wasn't even fully developed in his like
i mean that's vertex or whatever um yeah
and the thing about him is
we're very similar in personality and i
think he saw that in me
but he always wanted a boy because he's
a baseball player and so i think he
raised me like i was his son you know
not like a daughter and so he was really
hard on me and like discipline like i
had to really earn
things to to get uh his approval and and
even though that was like his way like
in his mind he's like i'm training you
to be the best to excel in things it
[ __ ] me up in the relationship
department because i felt like like with
guys i felt like i needed to do
something to gain i need to be
exceptional to gain your approval and if
you just liked me for just to like me
like i don't you're not even i don't
like you because like i don't trust that
like i didn't even do anything yet so
how could you like me right
uh the next one says i figured him out
when he began to project his
insecurities onto me and gaslight me
he'd say things like i bought you all
these nice things and you still want to
go out with your friends
oh like you could transact
oh yeah that's gross i've never had that
my ex we got into a massive fight
because he disrespected my family and uh
he just all he said it was just words
i'm sorry i'm like show some actions and
so
and i had to show teach him like show
some actions [ __ ] order food for me
in my family or something for disrupting
us or like get me flowers for once like
do something i want actions and he
finally did it only because i told him
to which is never
worth like it just doesn't mean anything
as much anymore and then a week later
he's like well i did the nice thing so
why are you oh god it's like yeah i give
you this so now i get to do whatever i
want exactly like it's so great out of
your heart yeah
yeah the transactional never feels good
no
uh the next one says i dated an ex for
three years that was incredibly abusive
in every way except physically though he
threatened it a number of times i can
only remember this incident towards the
end of the relationship i came home to
his house and there was a big bouquet of
flowers with a cookie from my favorite
place waiting for me all this from a man
who used to brag that a florist knew him
by name because he went there so much
for his exes but not once in our three
years ever brought me flowers he never
went out of his way to do anything nice
for me he came home that day and was
suddenly being really sweet asking if
i'd like the flowers and saying oh did
you see the cookie was from your
favorite spot at that point i had
already signed at least to move the hell
away from him and i was just waiting for
the keys i wasn't falling for it anymore
well what did i just say
what did i just say yeah it's
they do these nice things
at the very end like when it's do or die
and because you told them to yeah yeah
they're trying to hold on right and they
have to point it out like did you see it
i did it yeah it's like cool did the
good ones with the actual like um
diagnosed narcissist so from what i know
because i've never personally
experienced that but from what i know
they literally like to hold on because
it's fun so it's not that they love you
is that they have the hold on you that
where they like controlling you and
they're like haha i got her to do what i
wanted
and so when you finally leave and you
finally get the courage and you're like
i wasn't crazy i'm leaving
they be they try to become what you
wanted
and it'll work you know there's people
who go back five six seven times
and until you have enough and you
realize like it's never gonna change you
know
it's i i'm not gonna share who it was
but i have a friend who was dealing with
the narcissist and he lived out of state
so he was far
she would go out there and see him and
then when she was here in la he was like
i'm never going to get married i don't
love you i don't know why you're being
crazy like
crazy like that right
anyway eventually she ended up dating
and finding her current partner and in
the beginning she of her current
partner's relationship she texted the
guy and was like i'm sorry i'm blocking
you everywhere i no longer want to be
with you
leave me out of it leave me alone right
which with the narcissist it doesn't
work like that yeah so literally it was
so crazy to me because she told him that
and then she went on to her relationship
with her new boyfriend
that same week at six in the morning she
was at her mom's house
after her mom went to work he was parked
outside of her house waited until the
mom left to work because he knew she was
going to be by herself
knocks on the door so he doesn't call he
doesn't text knocks on the door
so then she opens obviously she's the
straw she just woke up she's not ready
so he caught her in a vulnerable
position
right after the mom left caught her in a
vulnerable position was like i'm here to
talk because you're not picking up my
phone calls yeah yeah no reason she said
but it's like as deep as the fact that
he caught her at six in the morning she
hadn't showered she wasn't ready she
wasn't ready physically she wasn't
already emotionally
and this is something narcissists do
they'll deprive you of sleep
to
get what they want out of you right and
so anyway they talk she texted her dad
like hey he's here
come out whatever the dad came or
whatever anyway they talked he left and
then he lives out of state and i believe
up until like six months after she was
still with her new boyfriend he would
come and like drop notes oh drop flowers
like it would be like we're meant to be
yeah we're gonna meet together forever
but the thing is like i'm like how does
your brain work yeah
you were telling this woman you were
never gonna marry her but all of a
sudden she moved on you always wanted to
marry her they can't believe that a
person would reject them yeah that
you're moving on yeah
um i learned that narcissists simply
they don't they don't love you because
they just don't love you it's literally
because they literally cannot yeah they
in their
something is up with their brain yeah
they literally just can't when they say
love it doesn't mean the same thing
exactly they don't have the they can't
grasp the same concept and i recently
was talking to my friend who's going
through his first breakup with a
narcissistic woman
and i was like you need to understand
that this is physically impossible
mentally impossible for them to do so
you can't just hold on maybe i can fix
it maybe i can do this like no it's not
the same you can literally [ __ ] gold
nuggets yeah make this woman come every
[ __ ] night give her all the money in
the world everything she's ever wanted
from a child you can give her the
[ __ ] dead dog she had from a child
yeah you know and bring it back to life
but it will literally never ever ever be
enough you'll never be enough because
that's not how they feel things they
feel things from manipulating it like
getting it's like a it's a whole it's a
whole trophy system like it's more of
about the like the chase the getting the
thing and and the conquering yeah than
it is about love there's no love they
can go to god himself and be like hey
can you put the perfect person in front
of me right now and it could be you and
it still won't be enough wow yeah that's
insane so like that's and it's very hard
for people to accept like but this
person that i spent this much time with
those so sweet no it can't be them like
no it really is them yeah the sun can
cost things yeah i was like well i've
already been with them for five years
like i just don't want to start over
it's like girl start over start over boy
start over yeah start over
have you ever wished for a best friend
with a medical degree to answer all your
sexual health and wellness questions the
favor medical team is just a text away
to guide you through your sexual health
and wellness options whether you're
thinking about going on birth control
for the first time need to renew your
prescription or want help finding the
best option the favorite medical team
has your back the pill club is now favor
favor offers professionally prescribed
birth control subscriptions and sexual
wellness products delivered straight to
your door for free no more going to
doctor appointments favor carries over
120 fda approved brands and ships to all
50 states most brands of birth control
are free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance
favor delivers birth control to your
door for free in discreet packaging
along with fun self-care gifts and
goodies that's way more than a doctor's
office that can give you that what's
more their licensed medical team is just
a text away to provide you the care you
deserve sign up for birth control in
just five minutes skip the office visit
and waiting in line at the pharmacy and
get treated right right now when you go
to hayfavor.com
big mood favor is offering a 10 donation
to bedsider.org for every big mood
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's
hayfavor.com
big mood to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember it's
hayfavor.com big mood you must use the
link to make a donation
every plate is america's best value meal
kit because while most meal kits come
with a premium price tag every plate
offers delicious dinners that won't
break the bank we love it let every
plate plan shop and deliver everything
you need to cook a delicious meal at a
consistently low price you can choose
from 17 delicious weekly recipes and
then
you just sit back you just like relax
they'll deliver pre-portioned
ingredients and then these easy to
follow recipe cards right to your front
door i got flatbread pizza
what else did i get oh gosh so many so
many things but the flatbread pizza
really stands out because
it was super easy who doesn't want pizza
at all hours of the day at any meal time
i had some left over i had some for
breakfast it was just a really good
value portion size
and every plate's quality ingredients
come carefully packed and pre-portioned
helping you save money and reduce food
waste every plate cuts out trips to the
grocery store and stressful meal
planning so you can enjoy cooking and
getting dinner on the table in just
about 30 minutes or less like this one i
think was less to be honest so get
started with every plate for a dollar 79
per meal by going to everyplate.com and
entering code bigmood179
that's everyplay.com and enter code
bigmood179
for just
seventy nine cents per meal that's up to
a hundred and four dollar value
everyplate.com code
bigmood179
uh number seven says everything i did
was amazing to them he got excited that
my favorite animated movie was a movie
he had only seen one time as a child he
didn't even remember it yet he cited
that as a re he cited that as a reason i
was perfect for him anything i did even
if it was directly conflicted with one
of his opinions would turn into yet
another reason i was perfect uh i
honestly didn't know this was love
bombing the concept makes so much more
sense now i hadn't actually treated me
like [ __ ] but our relationship started
out with him saying i was amazing just
because i knew who uh this character was
from the show i was insecure and took
the compliments where i could get them
even from a dude who seemed to only
brush his teeth once a week oh yeah
yeah okay
yeah that one's hard because
okay i don't uh i don't i didn't know
that was love bombing either but i did
um
like briefly dated guy that we weren't
ever like together but like he
was you know taking me out and stuff and
my
reason i didn't like him or couldn't
like
stay hanging out with him is that
whatever i said i was amazing and also
he agreed with everything i said like he
didn't have any opinions and it wasn't
like oh yeah i agree with you because
blah blah blah and here's all the
reasons i agree with you it was just
like yep me too
yeah that's it like we're small okay
cool so i just like
talked for 15 minutes about why i think
this thing and then you're just like
yeah
i agree
it's like i need more i need substance
tell me why i think we go back to that
point of like you have to be secure in
who you are yeah because if somebody's
like oh my god you're perfect because
you drive
this car it's like okay
surface level thing yeah i'm like yeah
yeah man like what's your point
let's keep going you know and so if
somebody's like you're perfect because
you like toy story
sure yeah anyway you know you're not so
blinded by the compliments on surface
level things or oh my god you're perfect
because you were your toenails are blue
you know you don't believe the simple
stuff you know what it reminds me a lot
of and this is true like if you are
wanting to be um
a youtuber or any sort of public figure
you cannot get so wrapped up in the
compliments that you think you're the
[ __ ] and you could not get so wrapped up
in the hate comments that you think
you're the worst and you want to die
because you're gonna get both extremes
and like i think seeing so many comments
at a time you really have to build a
firm foundation of of who you are or
you'll just get destroyed yeah like
don't get swept away by anything yeah
it's it's the same way in relationships
you know and if you're not used to
seeing that all the time like all the if
you're getting all the compliments in
the world you're like oh my god like i'm
the best like i feel so good with this
person or they take it away and start
telling you you're the worst and here's
all the reasons you suck and then you
start believing that because you don't
have that solid foundation yeah you give
somebody else you allow somebody else to
dictate who you are yeah exactly you
know you never get to decide who you are
you never get to tell people who you are
because you're waiting for somebody else
to tell you yeah i think uh an example
of this was when um
i this guy broke up with me because he
was like you're just too insecure
i
knew i wasn't insecure you know i knew i
was i've never been the insecure one in
the relationship
and so it when he randomly dumped me and
said yeah you're just being too insecure
because i brought up something that
really bothered me about another woman
um
if i had loved myself more and
understood myself more 100 of what i am
i wouldn't have been so hurt about that
breakup because i found myself asking
like am i insecure yes what that's weird
and then it really ate me up and then
later on i found out he'd cheat i was
like i wasn't insecure that was right
yeah they were throwing it on it was
deflection that same thing happened to
me at like where i was the remember the
topless photo i told you like where the
and then like oh no boobs are funny and
i was like i don't know if this is a
joke yeah because like that's weird i
wouldn't never do that like that's like
a this is kind of a flirty text and like
who is this girl i don't even know her
and he was like well well she spent the
night at our house when we were like
i'm like so she spent a night with you
and now she's throwing her boobs and he
was like you know you're too judgy yeah
things and i was like
i'm judging he's like yeah this isn't
the first time either like you judge me
on this this this like sometimes guys
and girls are just friends and they
should show boobs
and like never am i crazy like
you have to know who you are yeah oh
you're too judgy i am anyway
that you have boobs on your phone yeah
so what deal with that are you breaking
up or not yeah
like yeah
stop holding it against me yeah or like
when they try to say like you're too
sensitive yes i am let's move on yeah
are you going to deal with it or not
exactly you have to know who you are and
stand your ground on it i love that [ __ ]
yeah yeah [ __ ]
if you learn anything from this podcast
[ __ ] if i had to start over now i could
do it but yeah back in that like
sensitive zone that 24 year old that
said vulnerable little
baby time
yeah but i mean too nice it's okay yeah
it's okay to be nice yeah um it's just
when you're
when it's your heart's on the line
you can be a little bit of a [ __ ] yeah
you know and that's for like any maybe
24 year olds listening now like
your heart is your most precious
thing you have you know take care of you
yeah more than you're going to take care
of him oh my god i feel judged because
you don't let me get boop pictures okay
yeah feel judged yeah you know
yeah if it makes you uncomfortable then
stand by it yeah yeah yeah uncomfortable
or break up with me you know like
uh the next one says my now ex-boyfriend
wanted to get me a promise ring after
three months later added me to his life
insurance policy without asking me and
somehow made me out to be the bad guy he
said i was overreacting and that he just
was giving me the serious relationship i
wanted
look at all these things i did for you
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait okay hold on i'm confused
because
he gave her a promise ring and add her
to life insurance and she was like what
are you doing he never did anything bad
uh she said that he made her to be a bad
guy somehow
i need details because
if you give me a ring and add me to your
life insurance i'm like sure yeah like
i'm not tripping over that you know yeah
so that was a little bit weird maybe she
thought it was getting too serious too
fast and see like after three months i
would be like oh yeah that's fine like
you know so maybe like see that's that
fine line
when are you being love bomb and when
are you being like courted and taking
it's an individual situation yeah
because after that i wouldn't have been
like oh my god red flag yeah
and was like
you know making her feel like a like
she was taking from her his life because
look at all the things i did for you and
now and you're you're not you're going
to still go out without me or you're
going to still do things that you want
to do without me like that if
but he's just like oh it's a ring and
here like we're gonna you're on my phone
plan now then it's not a big deal yeah
if he had done that
like adding on the phone plan without
her asking
and suddenly turns around and says oh
now it's paid like i've been paying
extra
i pay for your flow now you're like what
i didn't ask for that there has to be
that twist
yeah for sure exactly where they turn
sour
the next one says any suggestion that we
slow down or not make big future plans
was met with sulking and the silent
treatment oh no i don't like that no
anybody that gives you a silent
treatment friend mom boyfriend anything
don't talk to them yeah
toxic
when you're in kindergarten you're
taught how to communicate your feelings
if you don't want to share a toy you're
taught to share like it's basic human
communication yeah when i was with my ex
every time we got into an argument he
wouldn't speak to me for it was always
three days it was always exactly three
days and then he'll message me plans how
did that feel and it was just like at
first i was like what the [ __ ] and then
after a while because i was so
used to it used to it
it became like a oh this is what he just
like also friday yeah exactly it's just
what he does and then later on after we
broke up i was like i don't want to
[ __ ] deal with that yeah that's lame
so and then whenever
he came back and just messaged me it was
just like a oh hey everything's cool now
it's like oh man that's that could mess
with you yeah he's like he was training
you to get used to that
so after we broke up i was like yeah i'm
not [ __ ] dealing with this because i
don't give silent treatments it's not
what i do i communicate same i've never
met anybody who does personally like to
me you know
i
like it's
childish and i don't like when things
are unresolved exactly i'll confront you
right away if i think there's a problem
because i just don't like an unresolved
tension type of issue yeah you still
have to be cordial like yeah coming in
good morning or like yeah i'm gonna go
to the store do you want anything like
even if we're mad like you don't just
get to treat me like i'm not in
existence yeah because you're upset like
that's traumatic it is it is and i was
and i was kind of like
i was trained to just mm-hmm like he
used to okay and when he comes back oh
yeah i missed him exactly yeah like i'm
going to give you attention now yeah
yeah mm-hmm okay i think you've had your
time out long enough i'm going to give
you attention exactly i'm going to treat
you like a person again oh no until you
[ __ ] up so don't [ __ ] up next time don't
pick up did you like that did you like
being
on timeout oh god
um this next one says a day after us
meeting he was texting me and telling me
what a good girl i was and he wanted a
future with me no he would insist i stay
on the phone with him as he slept even
though it made me super uncomfortable
the last straw was him sending hundreds
of messages in a row without response
and parking outside my house hoping to
catch me on my way to work no he texted
me from two different numbers for some
odd reason when i messaged him back and
told him it was all too much he said i'd
never find another guy like him when i
reminded him that i didn't care as i
wasn't interested he invited me out for
dinner and drinks and later that same
night told me to come over and watch
netflix we had only been on one date
that was a roller coaster i'll never
forget jesus this is a serial killer yes
you guys that friend that i was telling
you about that deal with the narcissist
yeah they would sleep on the phone every
night
like literally hearing each other
but it's because narcissists want to
mess with you and your sleep because
when you're sleep deprived you're more
likely to be like make them decisions or
agree to things or they could be like
you're just tired you're being dumb yeah
or like i remember you agreed last night
at three in the morning oh yeah you know
and so it's crazy that they sleep
deprive you like that it's to that
degree like where you sleep deprive and
you can't remember what you said what
you didn't say well you said half asleep
yeah you're tired at work and they're
like you get to sleep when i want you to
sleep oh my gosh yeah and they go to
sleep whenever they want to because
literally in the middle of an argument
be like you know what i'm tired i don't
want to deal with this yeah and he just
sleeps just fine and it got to the point
where my friend literally couldn't sleep
without talking to him on the phone like
she had to be on the phone with him and
they create that codependency wow it's
crazy oh yeah narcissists love
codependence yeah but codependency you
can work your way out of it like you can
get through it and you can establish a
non-code dependent behavior whereas
narcissism is that shit's permanent yeah
but say like if you're with the
narcissist you're never going to
establish
yeah you have to break away for sure and
that's what i went through because
i couldn't sleep well
if i didn't get like a face time with
him at night because somewhere in the
back of my mind was like
why aren't you calling me at night in
the morning do you have a [ __ ] over
and oh are you only calling me in the
morning after she leaves and it turned
out to be true
and it turned out to be true that's the
thing is that i felt like a shitty
person and this is a shitty thing
yeah yeah but i like went was going
through his phone and it became like a
second nature thing and i had never
looked through any other boyfriend's
phones and like i i never have looked
through steve's phone ever but for some
reason this [ __ ] dude but i was right
but it was still shady that i was
looking through a phone and i was like i
don't like who he i don't like what it
brings out of me because i know i'm
right and it's it's to the point where i
need evidence like to prove i'm not
crazy and that's why i'm doing it
because like i just
he makes me feel like i'm insane and
constantly doing the thing like you said
that oh no you don't remember that i
said that
and i'm like oh my god am i ins am i
crazy am i
i can't remember am i a bad person and
then i would find the evidence on the
phone and it was just a relief to my
sanity i'm not crazy
but then like you should know right then
and there if you're looking through
someone's phone you're not you should
not be with that person because there
are trust issues that that shouldn't be
ever a thing but i didn't know at that
time and and i never let that happen
again but it yeah i just felt like it
became a normal to like look for
evidence because i [ __ ] know
something's up yeah and then like that's
terrible can you imagine like all this
all the time you went through
all the stress and like anxiety that
didn't need to happen yeah because in a
healthy relationship those things just
don't happen but when you've never seen
a healthy relationship before you think
those things are normal yes like if you
grew up in a household where your dad
was abusive or where your dad didn't
show you love or like what the parent
like where a parent like withheld love
when they were upset when he where the
parent did the silent treatment you
think it's normal yeah and you're like
this is how all couples are i've never
seen a healthy couple that's so true
it you grow up you think
possible is what you've seen around you
yeah and so if you've never seen a
healthy relationship you're like i just
have to put up with it yeah
yeah
or like you just have to go through and
learn as you go because you were never
taught this when you were a kid yeah and
like you will your normal will will be
what you're surrounded by yeah you know
like when my grandma was young my
grandma's like they had kids in their
teens
and that was normal like now i'm 30 i
haven't had a child and they're like
that's so weird but to me that's normal
yeah to our group it's like yeah
everyone's having kids in their 30s yeah
that's just it
our lifespans are longer too now true
that could be it i mean my grandma's 90
but yeah yeah
but back when she was a kid their adult
life spans maybe
oh [ __ ] we have to have kids yeah
um the the the my friend that's going
through that uh breakup because this
person said he was like blowing up her
phone and stuff my friend is going
through the
narcissistic breakup right now she
at one point like a hundred and forty
five mistakes
45 missed calls and it would go from
it would go from i'm just gonna send a
video of me [ __ ] another guy [ __ ] you
you piece of [ __ ] too hey fly me out
like oh my cue
you're [ __ ] you i hope you kill yourself
too
can you call this club that you know and
get me in like it's insane yo that's why
well i guess this is a girl doing it but
like when it's a guy doing it
i'm like so i'm threatened not only are
you are you crazy but also i'm
threatened for my safety like i think
you're going to maybe murder me and
all the victims that i see on like like
dateline or whatever it's always like
someone that you know it's always
someone that you love and then they can
kill you yep
yeah and that's a scary thing like as
women it's not even only like your heart
it's your safety yeah exactly yeah
physical safety there was this girl on
tick tock you guys she was 19 years old
she was just married to a 20 year old
and they literally found her in a
bathtub full of acid
yeah and like
good looking guy good looking girl yeah
and you just think like oh they must be
like perfect he's so handsome
um you know and like literally he was
abusive yeah and the parents are like
she hadn't spoken to us in three weeks
we're so sad we want the daughter we
want our daughter back like
get out yeah i know it's so hard and
people are like it's not as easy as you
think i love him
get out if you can't it's the first sign
that you see
oh my god like it's never the victim's
fault but like
the first sign of disrespect is enough
don't wait until
it gets bad enough you know it's because
it's not even just like oh he's yelling
at me like at this point it's like
you will lose your life yeah it's that
serious yeah
it's so true all my friends who are cops
who dealt with domestic violence cases
they'd say all the time it never gets
better
it either gets worse or you die yeah
that's all there is to it those are the
only endings that's the only two endings
that you're going to get you know so
like at the first time that you got to
get out
and just as a side note that's like when
guys are like i don't get why girls have
to lie about having a boyfriend or
that's when they ask for i want to ask
for their number like dude because
there's some guys who don't take
rejection very lightly yeah and they
will [ __ ] murder you
that's why we feel like we have to
protect your fragile ego yeah exactly
um but there's so many more on the list
but we don't have enough time to go
through it so we're gonna but if you see
any of those love bombing signs now you
know
hopefully you never have to experience
them firsthand hopefully you can be a
[ __ ] in the beginning but be respectful
but
yeah be strict about yourself mm-hmm
and yourself love yourself and then that
way no one can ever make you think less
of yourself or think otherwise yeah
absolutely
people should just add to your life not
take away from it yeah keep that in mind
and uh hopefully you're all healthy and
safe and you're making good choices and
we will see you next time we're your
older sisters listen to us oh make sure
you follow stacey i'm like not so much
older because like we're very young like
just two months but follow stacy on all
four socials uh we'll link it down below
she has a cool jewelry line that you
guys should totally go buy some stuff if
not you're a coward until then i love
you we love you bye
[Music]
you